what's up everyone welcome back to the
collider studio at the supper suite at
tiff 2022 i am so excited to be talking
to the two leads of weird which
absolutely was the perfect way to kick
off the midnight madness lineup at this
festival last night good i could not
believe the energy in that room i mean
it's hard
there are a few rooms you walk into with
al that don't have just a huge amount of
energy and love for that man in them so
yeah it was and eric pointed out earlier
there's there's there's a a fairly
significant overlap in the venn diagram
of like owl fans and film nerds so i
feel like it's a it was a really perfect
and i use nerd obviously lovingly and
inclusively of myself but uh you know
it's a perfect place to start it oh
absolutely um so eric was supposed to
join us he's not here i did want to pose
my first question to you two in case you
knew this was the film always titled
weird the al yankovic story or was there
ever another idea floated because
there's so many different ways you could
form the fire dye one titled was it
titled weird i think it was i think it
was just i think it was also weird
yeah i don't think there was ever
another
i'm fascinated that you think that you
could i think to me there's only one
thing you could say because it could
just be weird it could just be the the
ali yankovic story yeah it has to be
dramatic though i think we i think i'm
sure eric like the idea of like a title
and a subtitle exactly like you don't we
really should have gone further with
that based on how long like al's tour
names are we could have had many
subtitles i also i feel like it could
have been one of those mile long titles
which would have been an seo nightmare
for us i'm glad you didn't do that all
right daniel my first question for you
now so i know eric and al were very
confident in you playing this role in
the film but when they came to you with
it how did you feel about your own
ability was there anything you circled
and said like listen i don't know if i
could do that i mean yeah the accordion
obviously but i i mean i i did um yeah
my first reaction was when they came to
me was like wait okay
like what um was very excited and
flattered but also not fully
understanding you know there would be
people that i would have think of as
more visually closer to al or people
would be a more obvious choice in that
way um but then as soon as i read the
script and i was like oh right that's
not what we're doing like accuracy is
not the name of the game here um and i
like
realized that you know
as soon as you read the script you're
like oh yeah al's biopic couldn't have
been anything else but this like it's
the perfect it's a a parody of the idea
of biopics and as eric said not just
music biopics but all of them um and uh
yeah so it i as soon as i sort of got
the joke and saw what was happening i
was like oh yeah i can i can see my way
into how i fit into this it really is a
genius idea to approach a biopic about
him it's amazing um evan for you given
given what daniel just said about the
script when you were first because i
think you said you got it in an email an
email that said do you want to play
madonna yes what were you thinking and
then what was your first reaction when
you read the script and realized what
kind of madonna you would be playing
i was just cackling the whole time i was
tackling the second i opened the email
and said you've been offered the role of
madonna and then i read
the premise i knew it was word out i
knew daniel was gonna do it and i was i
was just
over the moon immediately
and didn't stop laughing uh the you know
the entire time throughout filming
throughout everything it was just like a
joyous experience all around for
everyone really like cast crew
i mean it was just one of those things
where when you showed up to work it was
like if you're not having fun doing this
what are you doing
you could feel it while you're watching
i feel like that's the only way a movie
like this works if you have that vibe on
set yeah i don't know what this movie
would look like if we'd had a terrible
time shooting and it also would have
felt like i don't know like yeah what a
waste of life to be honest
and not have a good time yeah i know you
guys shot the movie in 18 days which
like my brain can't process that and i
know everyone always wants more time and
more money but is there anything about
about the way that this set operated
that you wished other sets out there
would do even if they had the biggest
budgets and many months to film i wish
everyone was committed and as good as
dan is at acting and knowing lines and
being fully ready and committed the
second things start rolling that's very
kind and
ditto um and i mean yeah like i don't
you're right this film doesn't get made
unless everyone from everyone in the
cast and the crew is like on it and
and also erica director was so prepared
like gonna say yeah it's you know it it
does it puts other sets to a little bit
to shame like when you're like okay you
because we shot for i mean so the whole
shoot was 18 days i shot for 14. you
shot for him maybe i only did a week
like eight maybe like seven or eight
days like it was it was really rapid so
unless um yeah
unless everyone is firing on all
cylinders it doesn't happen so it was
getting and that's what i love about
being on set is when you are you feel
like you're in the middle of this this
thing that everyone is working together
for this goal it's a really like
energizing experience so one thing about
your experience that i'm really curious
to hear more about is the fact that al
was physically there on set and i know
when you're making a biopic this is a
parody of course but i know when you're
in that situation it could be really
intimidating to have the real person
there but it sounds like you had a
really good collaboration so what is the
key to how the two of you work together
so you could strike that right balance
between you know bringing a degree of
truth to his story and honoring his
experience but having a role that feels
like your own and you have creative
freedom yeah i mean i think um i think
definitely there was a lot of license
and freedom was given by the fact that
it's not just like uh it's not just a
straight owl biopic and impersonation
like that i think gave you a lot of
freedom to be like okay you know it
doesn't this is a version of this person
um and i'm also really lucky that alden
knights and that he wasn't like sitting
on set like a hawk being like ah you did
that wrong you know he's very very
generous most of the notes um that i got
from him were musical and particularly
about the accordion like he was like can
you be a bit more expansive in how
you're pumping it like because i i don't
i you know you you're a bit cautious
with that and he's like very expressive
with it so i think he was a bit
concerned that i was gonna make him look
like a shy accordionist um and so he
yeah there was uh that but like
generally speaking
it was intimidating but also as evan
said earlier like that
when you would see him laugh at
something you'd be like okay great i can
go home like this is this is the yeah
it's a very good sale of approval
what about eric how can you tell when
you're absolutely crushing a take is
there anything he does behind the
monitor that gives you the feeling like
he's loving this right comedy it's like
if people are laughing then you're doing
it right yeah usually yeah and
especially on the like
yeah especially like
they're laughing and also frankly like
if they move on like if that's true
you're not doing that yeah if you're not
doing a third and fourth then you're
like okay we got it we're fine yeah i
need to go back to the accordion i love
i love music i love trying to pick up
new instruments for anyone out there who
sees this i have not so for anyone out
there who sees this movie and feels
inspired what is like a very basic 101
tip or trick that could you know get
them going with it a little quicker
um have a friend who is self-taught and
has the time to teach you because that's
what i did um
i
i wouldn't honestly even know how to
start i mean i'd say if anyone out there
who's got like some grounding in piano
will probably be all right because the
right half is is pretty much just that
i'm already screwed but if you're i mean
if you're somebody who can like if
you're good at the sort of you know
rubbing your belly and patting ahead
sort of thing then then you can do it
but i'm not so like both hands at once
was a nightmare but it is also a very
very fun instrument so i would encourage
anyone to to have a go all right maybe
one day i feel like the second you said
uh patting patting your hair i can't
even say it
patting your head and rubbing your belly
i can't do that i can't say that so i
don't know maybe i should explore
explore other avenues of music have you
ever been tempted to give it a shot
after the accordion yeah i i had one of
those little toy accordions uh as a kid
that's as far as i've ever gone no i had
my hands full
with madonna but i'm so happy they
didn't make me dance in this movie that
much because i am not as good of a
dancer as madonna she's like one of the
greatest dancers in the world so i mean
and he's like the greatest accordion
player in the world yes that was very
yeah
you
we signed karaoke with evan on the after
the wrap party i mean eric just had a
look a moment of look and she's got the
end it's an unbelievable singing voice i
mean eric were like ah we we've missed
an opportunity here really to have us
sing in the movie that was dumb how did
we not let this happen
i still listen to the across the
universe soundtrack
regularly my whole family loves that
movie it's one of those things that will
always bring us into the same room if
it's on uh that makes me so happy
because that's exactly what it's for
yeah i love it so much
is madonna aware at all of what has
happened here
if she is she is not letting on and but
honestly like she is like the busiest
woman in the world she's got other
things to do on her mind she's got her
own biopic going on i'm sure this is not
even a blip on her radar
i did i did like in the i think in the
new york times article there was a
little bit where it said like madonna
has not responded to comment i was like
did you ask is it because it's a cool
thing to write it's a cool thing to make
it sound that was
really aren't like are there any nerves
that she's like it is parody it is all
in good fun she's kind of the villain of
the story
well exactly i mean that's that was my
saving grace is like none of this
actually happened so i think i'm i'm in
the clear with madonna here i think it's
okay yeah i think it's so
insane and extreme that like it's i i'm
i'm it's i think i'm hoping she finds it
funny if she is aware of it at all i
think we need to build a parody
cinematic universe and madonna should be
so inspired by your performance that she
wants to play your madonna parodies in
another movie my parody of madonna
that's like we the yeah that's insane my
mind is broken
if you both had the opportunity
to parody another artist in in any form
of uh art creation storytelling in
another movie who would you pick and why
god
this is really tough i i have
oh man i felt bad coming up with the
question because i couldn't think of a
good answer for myself what are you
doing here why have you done this to us
um
i don't know why i just thought of bill
murray was the first thing that like
came into my head i was like i yeah i
would love to i would i would watch a
parody of his life the movie where you
play bill maher that's what i mean yeah
i'm going to play bill murray yeah
what about here's another angle to that
what if you could parody one of your own
past films or shows which would you pick
feels like harry potter's probably been
dancing i know it's gonna say
oh my goodness
something else yeah uh
potter would be i mean potter's
definitely the richest one for uh
there's a lot you can take in there for
sure i was just thinking you should make
it like a parody movie about the daniels
how i don't know how how can you get
more extreme than that i honestly don't
know but i want to experience everyone
else
i'm just i just want to see whatever
they do next i'm like yeah i guess a
little off track here but like what what
do you think about the response to
everything everywhere all at once
specifically the fact that it's getting
oscar buzz right now it should it should
we have a very narrow focus of what an
oscar movie is though so i think it's
can't believe that it's like impossible
to deny what that film's done and
how
uh you know they've made this insane
film full of the biggest ideas and the
craziest storytelling but it's also
still like incredibly beautiful and
heartfelt and funny and fun the whole
time um that's it's the best film i've
seen years it should be up for all of
them i think and yeah i just i it makes
me it's weird to have like one of my
favorite films directed by people i know
now it's very slightly awkward i feel
weird telling them about it but it is
it's incredible i mean they've deserved
the awkwardness they've sparked in you
um back to your movie now so again
really crazy 18-day
shoot here is there any particular scene
that you kind of like circled in red and
said i really wish i had more time to
prep for that scene because it's going
to be really difficult to just jump
right into it
um i guess the the there was the only
thing that i remember us being like oh i
would love another couple of takes if
that was the fight scene in the diner
like there are some things in in that
which like there were
uh we literally did one of and it was
whatever eric had was what he used um
but it's still like a scene i'm a messy
proud like that scene was shot in four
hours and like that
like
i know it's crazy seriously eric is like
an extraordinary director like leader on
this project because it
it didn't feel like it was 18 days and
that's what's really weird it's like we
fell into this vortex where time didn't
exist
we somehow had enough time but it was
still the shortest shoot in my life yeah
well i mean that's one of the special
things about a shoot like this i feel
like sometimes no matter how much money
and no matter how much time you have
then you kind of like reduce your
ability to find that like random onset
magic that you would if you had all
those i guess speaking of that what
scene would you say change the most from
script to you know finding that magic on
set in the moment i think a lot of the
film was like they're on the page like
there was that we would improvise
sometimes a little bit but like most of
it um i mean and then occasionally like
i
like the the party scene around the pool
party like that was what was my favorite
scene in the film i mean those scenes
where you know uh eric is just shouting
at yormo like do the dance and like so
there's still like you know there were
moments like that but but generally
speaking
again like such to keep repeating it's
such a tight shoot but like
most of it was there like it was all the
insane stuff that if anything looks like
i'd lived it was it was probably not it
was probably in the stress same for you
evan is there anything that like came to
you on the moment in the moment on the
spot no but you know because yeah again
again it was a short shoot and so you
don't get to improvise as much you kind
of like stick but we would throw in
jokes here and there every now and then
uh but yeah for the most part it was
absolutely
on the page i'm trying to think of
anything we added but it was there yeah
well i mean if this was what was on the
page better off that you stuck with it
because it's very funny and i could keep
you here all day literally talking about
every single set piece in this film
huge huge huge congratulations enjoy
tiff thank you for being here thanks to
everybody out there watching we'll see
you soon more tip 2022 interviews